6 22 it's friday morning three on three
ice hockey it's exhausting but it is a
lot of fun it's amazing the plates three
and three hockey full-size rink nhl
overtime format and it's all based on
three ice it's uh
happening here in las vegas this weekend
founder and ceo ej johnson is with us
this morning good to see you sir great
to be here thank you so for those who
don't know uh tell us about the three
ice hockey league so it's basically
overtime all the time the nhl's three on
three session is what we've taken as our
full-time format and it is hair on fire
track meet hockey it is breakaways two
on ones three unknows we even had a
goalie try and score one time this year
oh yeah it is wild if you're a hockey
fan you'll love it if you're a sports
fan you'll love it but just
entertainment seekers as well and if
you've been to the golden knights game
this is essentially what happens if it's
tied at the end of regulation they play
three on three first before the shootout
this is just all three on three time so
this has been going on for a good
portion of the summer here tell us about
the players who are involved and how
everything has sort of led to being at
the orleans this weekend yeah we got
young guys that can fly so our average
age is about 29 years of age a lot of
these guys played in the nhl all the
european leagues ahl echo guys i like to
say we're looking for ferraris and
maseratis these water bug type body
types that can just zip around the ice
we don't want those big mac trucks so it
is just electric back and forth hockey
so for us six teams show up you play a
bracket style tournament three opening
round games two semi-finals and
championship
this weekend it's just our top four
teams competing for a million dollars
yeah that's a lot of money on the line
for these guys and the team's only about
seven eight guys so that's a fair chunk
of change here um for the players and
it's not just the guys on the ice i
personally as a hockey nerd love the
fact that the the people behind the
scenes the coaches we're talking hockey
legends grant fjord former edmonton
oilers goalie brian trottier legend uh
larry murphy joey mullen some legends of
hockey that are involved in this as well
we have 23 stanley cups between our
coaches then you got craig patrick won
the gold medal in 1980 he's got about
four or five cups he's in the hall of
fame every one of these guys in the hall
of fame a lot of pittsburgh connections
i'm a pittsburgh guy yeah your dad of
course was
involved in that and that's right won a
couple cups as well that's right he's
got about five rings actually so uh if
people want to go see this this is at
the orleans uh tomorrow tell us about
the deal with tickets and how they can
get involved sure so you can get tickets
at 3ice.com you can walk up to the
orleans we drop the puck at one o'clock
we go for two hours it's going to be
fantastic stuff it's so much fun and
like you said it's fast paced you sit
down it's just zipping up and down the
ice not a lot of whistles right it's
just constant action two face-offs one
to start each period we play two eight
minute halves and it's just go go go we
play the puck off the netting if it
comes in uh clean we have uh jailbreak
penalty shots so instead of going to a
four on three power play drop the puck
at center ice everybody chases the guy
and it's live it's just wild stuff i
feel like especially for a lot of young
kids because a lot of them are all
focused on skill these days that are in
hockey this that's what you're gonna see
just fast a lot of skill a lot of fun
and it's an affordable way to spend a
saturday that's it it's tic-tac-toe
passing great skating and just a lot of
creativity and there's some stuff out
there that guys are doing that you see
in video games picking the puck up
lacrosse style twirling around and
snapping in the net it is wild it's just
it's great stuff i love it e.j johnston
from three ice hockey go see it over at
the orleans again tomorrow for starting
at one o'clock looks like a lot of fun
good to meet you thank you likewise all
right just